- In one episode--
you're going to shake your
head-- your daughter--
GLORIA ESTEFAN: Yes.
- In effect calls you out
about the fact that she is gay
and she says that you were
reluctant to let her tell
her grandmother that she had
come out before her grandmother
passed away.
GLORIA ESTEFAN: In
the Latin community,
a lot of these subjects
aren't touched.
They're taboo.
People see but they don't
want to talk about it.
They don't want to see it.
I have all these people that
have loved me through the years
and supported, and I want
them to realize that we're
all just families, trying to get
through the difficult moments
in life.
Emily, I thought, would feel
comfortable coming out to me.
We've been very, very
open about the support
for the LGBT community
our entire lives.
And at the same time I had a
mother with ulcerative colitis
that, even if I brought up
a bill or something that
was not even important,
would get very upset
and would get sick.
So, yeah, and life
is complicated.
Life is tough.
And we wanted to share
those things with people
so they would realize these are
conversations we need to have.
And it really was
wonderful, the response.